ready for ravers Christmas and New Year
party season is one of the most
lucrative times of the year for
nightclubs but post-pandemic they're
continuing to struggle with a third now
being forced to close
those still open say a perfect storm is
making it extremely difficult to operate
after two years of kovid where we were
like hoping for a big comeback
of of having fun of parties of coming
bringing back our businesses to pay back
our big loans that we've taken during
covet we thought this is our time and
the economy again gone and we have the
uh living crisis started and the war in
Russia and Ukraine and
yeah everything hit us so hard at the
same time
the nighttime culture economy brings in
36.4 billion pounds and also provides
425
000 jobs across the UK it's also an
essential part of the music industry's
ecosystem Grassroots is where I started
my my music so I was in those clubs I
was in the social club like practicing
and DJing so for me working my way up
from a young kid with aspirations and
dreams to actually been able to perform
Grassroots the clubs are everything to
me and I really hope that that maintains
the same and clubbers will lose out as
venues close their doors permanently
coming to places like this for drinking
and dancing has been a big part of
British culture for decades but if these
spaces are left empty it'll put a hole
in the industry and could force music
lovers Underground
what we're concerned about is we're
going to get to a point the clubs are
going to be lost at such a level that
people are just going to decide to start
looking at other sites and places which
are unregulated potentially don't have
the safety protocols in place the
license is the security Etc and that's
where there is a real fear there are
cause for the government to help the
nighttime economy by freezing alcohol
Duty or helping with vat bills as
without support it will be the last
dance for many venues Claire Gregory Sky
News